dass wir unternehmer vergessen wurden in
meinen augen hat mich extrem wütend
gemacht ich persönlich bin 38 jahre alt
ich bin sehr besitzer von software shop
von apple hairdressing und konsum eps
effekt das sind 3
dienstleistungsbetriebe im youtube
bereich und platz für ich mit meiner
familie
[Musik]
ich bin generation merkel weil das was
mich am meisten geprägt hat war der satz
wir schaffen das aber wir haben es nicht
geschafft
[Musik]
der staat hat mich gezwungen mein laden
zu schließen dadurch entstandenen
schulden bei meinem vermindern und
anderen gläubigern an denen ich keine
schuld trage ich durfte es nur ein bis
zwei wochen hochs wieder in einen laden
eröffnen kannst und wie immer wieder was
versprochen wird und dann passiert das
nicht und dann auf einmal hört dabei in
einem anderen bundesland ist das wieder
in ordnung bei dies ist nicht in ordnung
da kannst du nur frustriert sein hier
sind wir in meinem baby mein eigentum
ein reich der dogs barbershop
ja ich sag immer so wenn man sich dieses
jahren anschaut mein hirn an die wände
des blätter nach dem sex passiert ist
[Musik]
ich habe nicht aufgaben und als ich
wieder aufmachen durfte natürlich habe
ich den ersten ansturm gehabt aber
danach hatte ich echt nichts lautet erst
mit erst gerade wieder besser weil der
lockdown grundsätzlich aufgehoben wurde
so kann ich entspannt arbeiten
man können dann müssen wir auch gleich
kommen eigentlich
das auch schon aber es geht wo alles
passen bei der alles klar
wie hast du deine test dabei
muss sollte wieder deswegen extra
schlange stehen für dich
peter 24 freiheit so sieht so aus jetzt
kann ich alles machen da ist fertig
jetzt gut wenn du in den genuss eines
hart trifft es bei mir kommen möchtest
dann musst du dich registrieren also
entweder durch die luke ab oder du musst
deine daten einmal aufschreiben also
alleine der termin reicht nicht du musst
eine maske tragen dann musst du einen
tagesaktuellen gronert es mitbringt
mitllerweile du kannst du dir selbst
mitbringen und die vor meinen augen
machen wenn ein kunde auch noch kommt
und kein fest hat da muss er ja fest
hier machen schnell festigen die plastik
versucht ja aber das dauert etwa 20
minuten ist eigentlich auch die kunst
und das war es dann mit dem termin durch
die regelung habe ich definitiv unsere
umsatzeinbuße
nein aber noch was wisst dass ich bin
vollständig geben
wow
es wird ja mal gesagt ja gut als fünfter
hat man mehrere vorteile man darf wieder
das leben so genießen wie es vorher war
so ein stück leben aber ich muss sagen
also da ist keinerlei veränderung im
mieterin nun durfte sich ja erst mal ich
und du bist aus dem lebensmittelbereich
und ich bin
also körpernah dienstleisters ich bin
genauso narben arzt da und ich gehöre zu
keiner priorität priorität ist ist das
sowieso schwachsinn aber also zum
beispiel meine schwester wofür sich
zuerst jahr mit dem kindergarten meine
oma dürfte sich noch nicht impfen lassen
und de schon über 80 meine schwester
durfte schon und dann war ich der
nächste und erst dann durfte auch meine
oma sich hinters
hat vor nicht sicher aber ich war
trotzdem total froh dass wir durch sind
[Musik]
die jungs hier im hintergrund wirklich
jeden freitag da und ja ich würde sagen
da hat sich definitiv eine freundschaft
entwickelt auch wenn sie deutlich jünger
sind als ich ich glaube sind auch öfters
mal an was ich sage weil ich ein
bisschen mehr lebenserfahrung habe aber
sie zeigen mir auch wiederum wie das ist
jünger zu sein 20 zu sagen die zeit zu
nehmen mitten im leben jetzt zu stehen
ich denke ich sage so etwas wie die ard
bringt aussagen die ich er manchmal
nachvollziehen kann bezüglich der krise
ganz dünnes eis mehr aber ihr wisst ganz
genau trotzdem so eine aussage wie zum
beispiel zwei haushalte dürften sich
nicht treffen aber 80 leute im bus wir
wissen alle dass die iaaf die gesagt
haben ihr anhang an jemanden nicht
zustimmen wenn ich weiß was seine
anderen werte sind also weil er in einer
sache recht hat und den ich sollen dann
die anderen 99 sachen vergessen das ist
es kann nicht mehr stehen das ist eher
traurig dass meine regierung der ich das
vertrauen schenke nicht
so'n aussagen treffen kann und dass
jemand den ich einfach verabscheue und
schlimm finde dass der mir nach dem mund
redet aber das ist ja das denke ich habe
die du du du greifst doch also du weißt
doch gar nicht ob das deren meinung ist
und du greifst einfach nur die
triggerpunkte
bedient sich sicher eine krasse
außenseiter mir ist es gibt kein töten
in deutschland denn die erste ideen will
in 100 jahren nicht haben wird nicht
passieren und egal was sie sagen sie
können auch sagen freibier für alle mit
nicht wirklich passieren
lösungsansätze fehlen was willst du
machen öffentliche verkehrsmittel wie
willst du das geklärt ich kann dir ganz
einfach lösen
ganz so locker sechs wochen alles zu was
hat das hat spanien gemacht dass er
portugal gemacht waren indes portugal
ist wieder im arsch sydney kompletter
locker und jetzt auch wieder es ist ein
interessantes gebracht jetzt einfach die
nächste frage ist dann ob dort überhaupt
den weg
irgendwie ja da ich bin kein biologe ich
kann ja immer nur meine eigene meinung
irgendwie reagieren wo die nicht
erzählen da ich würde sagen ja schon
also teils teils schon ein halber
lockdown effektiver leisen sohlen
lockern leitung so ein bullshit ja aber
das ist ja das ist wohl das was die
regierung gemacht hat genau das ist es
doch und das ist doch nur über sich die
leute auch aufbringen das mögen die
menschen unzufrieden deswegen verlieren
gastronomen doch ihre geschäfte auch
kommen wenn die leute sich unvernünftig
irgendwie verhalten würden dann hätten
wir das problem auch nicht guckt ihr die
leute mal im stadtpark an guck mal war
es schon wieder passiert du gibst den
kleinen finger du darfst bis 0 uhr
irgendwo sitzen und ihren reihen laufen
wenn du das willst mach das und gehen
danach nach hause du kriegst auch den
kleinen finger nein stattdessen ziehen
weiß nicht wie viele tausend menschen
2000 menschen sind in den stadtpark und
feinarbeit habt ihr nichts also ihr habt
nichts wahrgenommen den letzten zwei
jahren scheint ja genau das hat mich
halt wieder ab ja ich kann ich ja
komplett nachricht scheint da wär ich
hätte den haben wieder alles dicht
gemacht nach dem ersten abend in der
schanze wo die da autokorso unsere stadt
er hat das kotzen bekommen ja aber das
aber kommt gegen das ihr habt ja nicht
raus gelernt ja weil aus emotionen
spricht aber jetzt haben wir zudem macht
alle ziele nicht dann mache ich meinen
laden zu brauchen christian die haare
nicht mehr geschnitten und dann das hat
der sachse aus der emotion oder aber mir
geht es um mein leben der ja weißt du
was ich meine und kann sich über die
kleinen spaß ist aufregende das machen
aber brauchen bei mir geht es um mein
leben ich habe hier mein leben drin und
das ist mein blut die leute dies zu
verantworten haben ist es richtig machen
es muss funktionieren dinge ganz einfach
wir sind auf jeden fall nicht immer
einer meinung aber das wäre ja auch
langweilig aber das ist auch
kommunikation irgendwie dass man das
aber was sagt das b was sagt dass man
das nachvollziehen kann und versteht
wenn man dann auf einen gemeinsamen
nenner kommt dann ist das der
optimalfall aber sonst es macht auch
spaß mit ihr zu diskutieren
bruder fällig
dass wir unternehmer vergessen wurden in
meinen augen hat mich extrem wütend
gemacht wenn man überlegt bei drei
geschäften wie viel miete zahlen muss
und welche die fixkosten ich habe schöne
gut wir werden 90 prozent von übernommen
aber die restlichen zehn prozent bei
drei geschäften ist eine menge geld
also mich hat krone ja noch härter
getroffen als manch anderen weil ich
hatte keine rücklagen deswegen brauchte
ich zum beispiel die unterstützung
meiner mutter und das willst du als 40
platz 40 jähriger mann nicht was
möchtest du nicht hier merkt man dass am
stärksten glaubt hier an dem laden ist
es gleich zu sehen also das war ein
riesen das war sogar eine kette die hier
glaube ich mal drin war selbst sind
draußen
ist zu sehen und spürbares corona
eingeschlagen hat
[Musik]
natürlich aufgrund der pandemie hat man
existenz 6 da kann man nichts gegen
machen dass familienvater sein ist in
mir drin ist es war keine motivation für
mich fremd zu sagen ich handle jetzt so
oder so weil ich familienvater bin
sondern das ist bei das bin ich einfach
und die pandemie hat mein denken mein
bewusstsein ganz stark verändert
jetzt aber küche
[Musik]
wie war es ja alles gut die mädels an
alle da ja wir hatten gut zu tun und die
kinder
ja auch grund dessen dass wir in
familienunternehmen sind und jeder in
der familie sozusagen sein geschäft
führt sie muss natürlich nicht so oft
wie werden wir zum beispiel alle in
einem laden arbeiten würden aber ich
glaube wir sehen uns auch nicht weniger
als wir andere menschen die in
irgendeiner anderen beruf jeweils
arbeiten doktor war das schon so das
wir-gefühl die fülle sind achterbahn
gefahren wir sind immer mal ab und da
uns gehabt weil wir wussten nicht wie
lange es ist noch ist dieser zustand
noch da und ich wurde da so
alleingelassen
einfach alles dicht gemacht keinerlei
einnahmen mehr gehabt und ich bin bis
jetzt immer wien gegangen und wusste
eigentlich auch immer genau
wofür welche partei steht du musst du
genau dahinter stehe ich dann noch die
wenig auch aber jetzt nach dieser
pandemie für mich sind die ganzen
politiker überhaupt nicht mehr
vertrauenswürdig so
von der politik wünsche ich mir was die
familienplanung angeht eigentlich
grundsätzlich gar nichts weil ich habe
mir das unternehmertum ausgesucht
selbstständig und das ist mein weg ich
habe dafür dadurch sehr viele vorteile
habe aber auch mega viele nachteile von
der neuen bundesregierung wünsche ich
mir eigentlich wieder mehr sicherheit
für unternehmer nicht das gefühl zu
haben allein gelassen zu werden
ich habe so das vertrauen ich fand immer
deutschland war so ein land für
unternehmer für selbstständige und ich
finde dass so kleine und
mittelständische unternehmen extrem
schlicht belassen worden und ich fühle
mich einfach nicht mehr sicher und ich
wünsche mir sicherheits und
[Musik]
noch mehr power generation merkel findet
ihr in der mediathek
[Musik]